well we are still waiting for an
official word on Red Dead Redemption -
but in the meantime you can get a taste
of the series roots with Red Dead
Revolver on ps4 rockstars Red Dead
Revolver has been re-released on Sony's
console and is available to download now
through the PlayStation Store the game
is priced at $14.99 and features full
1080p up rendered visuals on top of the
upgraded graphics the ps4 version
supports features such as trophies share
play Remote Play activity feeds and
second screen support for game manuals
with the PS Vita or PlayStation app Red
Dead Revolver was originally released
for PlayStation 2 and Xbox in 2004 it
started life as a Capcom title but
Rockstar purchased the rights when it
acquired angel studios the team that
would go on to become Rockstar San Diego
a follow up the highly acclaimed Red
Dead Redemption was released for
PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 in May 2010
unfortunately it is not playable on the
PlayStation 4 but it was added to the
list of titles supported by Xbox one
backwards compatibility in July in May
take two rockstars parent company said
it will announce new games soon but that
none of these will be out until April
2017 at the earliest
although Red Dead Redemption 2 has not
been anounced in any official capacity a
map from a possible Red Dead Redemption
to leak appeared online earlier this
year take two also previously said that
the Red Dead franchise is considered a
permanent one by take-two in game spots
Red Dead Revolver review the game earned
a 7.3 for more on Red Dead in whatever
Rockstar is cooking up stay tuned to
game spot
you
[Music]